now I will actually take this
opportunity like I do a bit too just now
to say like yeah it took me ages to draw
this volume well but drawing it well is
a critical skill like seeing what the
volume is it's worth investing the time
to draw your diagram properly so you
don't screw it up so you understand it
well and you can form the integrals
properly like no kidding when they say a
picture says a thousand words this very
clearly demonstrates what's going on and
I'm going to draw so I'm going to make
some arguments off the base of this
diagram so it better be good enough it
has behavior for you um sometimes yes
and sometimes though it depends it
depends on the difficulty all the volume
that you get and also like whether they
try and like what are they try to assess
basically right as I've explained what
kind of understand as I've explained
before as your further the volumes get
more difficult and so you don't you will
often get give it a draw and just there
you go you get given them okay now I've
actually got a little bit further then
are what a typical question would do and
this is the reason why I've highlighted
this agree a common way that you would
see this is they will give you this
function give you the straight line I
tried the crab luck give it a straight
line and then they'll shade this
together they say that area the part
shade of green that's all we give you
and they tell you what access in it
you're rotating around okay and then you
have to say well okay it's up to you
whether you want to draw a decent
diagram or not then you've got to for
the integrals and evaluate and you can
see just by looking at this right that
there's going to be this cabaniss hole
in the middle now this diagram is very
busy I actually think it's worth having
invested really well to make this a good
big diagram with colors and everything
okay off on the side here as a small
version I'm going to draw another
version of this but with less
information on it so that i can just see
the volume so if you want to imagine
what i'm doing is i'm looking at this
I've actually looking from this angle
like literally where I'm standing so
that i can see i'll call this the top I
can call whatever line I'm seeing this
part and these parts in here are hidden
from my view right does that
sent that's why I've draw the miss dolly
okay so if I me me doing that and gave
the smaller version up here I've got the
top there right the outsides are kind of
like a bowl right come like a boulder
tapering in in this curd way like this
that's curved okay then you've got the
bottom but then there's a slice chug
that's been cut out from the middle okay
so you can see here it's on this inner
ring like that again it's something
that's hidden from your view and those
edges on the inside is straight so this
is the actual volume that we are dealing
with okay now just to help you'll see
this word refer to later on that part
that I've cut out from the middle right
can you see because it's got straight
edges right if I were to continue that
all the way and get a code when you if I
went until those two opposite sides met
okay now because it's basically like a
cone but I've sliced off the top right
it gets a new name on this thing the
inside shape is called a frustum okay so
you might say that word they won't
expect you to know what it means like
just by saying it it's a frustum that's
very very unlikely if they said that
word they'll almost certainly provide
you a diagram like I have but you might
as well know what it is because well
it's all that complicated to work out
ready so basically it's a comb with a
smaller code cut off the top if that
makes sense okay so how do I determine
this volume okay I've got a big bowl
view which I can work out from the
parabola right and I call that because
the bigger one I call it the outer
volume right so i'm going to say alta
bullied eagles now i haven't provided
you boundaries yet so just because of
the functions that I've chosen I think
the values I wanted were yeah i'm going
to call this 15 this 150 my scales not
most fantastic but hopefully the rest of
the diagram makes up for that okay
sobeit those are my ex boundaries and
I'm rotating around the x-axis I can say
that the outer volume is the integral
from five to fifty of what this is the
other boleyn name right pi first and
then it's going to be y squared DX right
which because why is the squared of X Y
squared is just X that's a perfect there
you go no problems right now this is
fine to integrate I will do this in a
second okay but then I want to point out
once we finish this off and get a number
at the end yeah but that's not the
actual volume by one I've got to take
I'm going to cut this slice out like
this big chunk so because it's on the
inside I call that the univ ollie okay
and you know value shares the same
boundaries it is still from five to 15
right but it's all been completely
different function right so this is what
I've got here and I need to evaluate
that as that's why I need Y squared
right so I've got pi times that sweat
there's my wife's where are you happy
with that with respect to X okay now
what's going to ensue after this is
honestly just a bit of monkey work and
I'm going to let you do that without me
without having to watch this because you
can do it yourself probably quicker than
i can but you can see there to get the
actual volume I've got the big one I've
got the small one once I've got both of
them I just hit the difference that's
all I need to do right so I'm going to
give you a middle or two to actually
just do the arithmetic first evaluate
your integrals take out whatever
constants are suitable to make this easy
for yourself and then we'll come back
together when we're combining the
results of you okay so you do that also
do on the wall
what do you do like it can you like I'm
going to tell you about that in a bit
for now treat them as separate for you
okay because i'm actually going to draw
a particular point out of that I've do
the volume separately and then some fact
we'll come back together let's try the
strands back together and point out a
couple of things right like I said um
this one's pretty easy it's pretty
straightforward okay you'll notice I
pulled up that too as sore as as soon as
I saw it in the primitive because I'm
like well I can do it once at the front
rocking it twice I prefer to do it once
over here you can see I could have
expanded this guy but it's simple enough
that I can just say well i'm just going
to be raising a parent / that power the
chain rule the reverse chain rule is
exceedingly simple because X doesn't
have a coefficient on it so that
derivative would just be one doesn't
have an effect okay and you can quickly
test this like if you differentiate that
sure enough okay in the same way i took
this three board out the front which is
how that 300 came out and then a pretty
sure i evaluate okay now this all came
together in this line you'll notice by
the way in previous questions where it's
like I've got this point into that
volume I would have said total volume
but i'm not actually adding things up
and taking a difference so that's why i
say actually i mean you can say whatever
you like you can just say volume full
stop if you want so only to distinguish
what's going on you've got three
different quantities going on here so
don't confuse them one take away the
other you simplify tada okay now the
question was raised earlier and it's
actually part of why i'm drawing this
out this particular way well hold on a
second when were there doing like if the
question i posed to you was tell me what
the green area is its work out the green
area forget about the volume for a
second okay the way to work at the green
area is to say this is an area between
two cars so you would say the area is we
talked about upper function in lower
function right so you go this guy take
away that guy between the boundaries so
you'd go five to fifty all the tub look
square root of x take away one tenth
blah blah blah blah that would give you
the green area thumbs up okay it's not
unreasonable thing
okay well if i just take in that area
and then rotating it around can I just
take this guy right and do the PI R
squared H but can I not do that right
would this volume right rather going
through this separate way could I treat
this as a single volume with the pie and
the r should have picked this is one
squared and the H now the answer is no I
want you to think for a second with me
as to why the answer is No okay oh the
first I just want you to be content with
the fact that how did how did we come
about with this volume is volume and
then subtract what how did we argue that
do you agree with it do you agree that i
went about it in my way like there's a
big boy i cut a hole out of it right so
I work out the big one work out the hole
and then i subtract that works right you
contend with that yeah is it because you
can tell you like the cylinders inside
so if you try and cut like biggest limo
and then a smaller field dog like you're
actually yeah like I don't have to fight
it but it's very high you're on the
right track you're on your very much on
the right track think about what you get
here right and if I take out one slice
in fact let's just have a look at this
tops I see because I'm kind of already
grown right if I just give it a tiny
infinitesimal thermal with okay the area
of this little slice that we're taking
out right is not a syllable okay in fact
it's the difference between two
cylinders now if I were to do this right
this part here what this does is it
takes one radius the root X Reyes that's
this one right sorry that rate is there
and it takes the other one and it puts
them together right so when you
calculate this what you're going to get
is a cylinder okay just one cylinder
you're not going to get this sort of
eval it's like a washer right like with
a hole in the middle okay now algebraic
that I can prove this for you very
simply this is what I've done and I'm
actually going to ask you to put this
over the top of this maybe in like big
colorful
that is in a box when you're working out
of all you and you're doing the
differences okay you have to go integral
right from whatever boundaries you
choose you got the pie in there okay but
what this amounts to if you do want to
put it together as one integral is
there's a big radius that gets squared
and then there's a little radius that
gets squared okay there's the big one
there's the little one you can combine
those and there's your DX what's your
different integrating with respect to
okay and that is fine now this is saying
something quite different right do you
see the subtle difference what this is
saying I put a move in with danger honk
okay it's not that rather it's trying to
say this a big pie and then it brings
the radii together like this okay now
these are not the same right once i get
all the algebraic way you can see that
these are different in fact if I would
evaluate this right see this Y minus y
square it's going to become y squared by
this to y y plus the other y squared
this is totally different you're doing
in not subtracting this volume at all
and you get this reader guy in the
middle just like what is that okay this
is not the volume this is something
dramatically different such as
clarifying the music properties or
engines you can just break your back
it's exactly the correct that's right so
what I've done is this is the correct
way the accurate way to contract these
two integrals together right this one
has been square that's why it's an X lot
of square roots this one has been
squared and then i can combine them like
so right there already being squared as
opposed to combining them first and then
squaring later which gives you a
completely different volume all together
okay so watch out right this is the way
we do areas but it's not the way we do
volume it doesn't work when you do
that's why I sent differences between
volumes work out the values first one
two and then take a difference okay easy
trap to foliage
thank sense